welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and one division's darkest and most
cryptic details are now coming in these
west view commercials the most recent of
which terrifyingly starves a child to
death and erodes him like a nazi in an
indiana jones movie
he chose poorly with some reports saying
that after
six half-hour episodes and all nine
episodes quoted to be a total of six
hours of content that these final three
might be closer to an hour long each
making us really only halfway through
this series now there's only so much
promo footage that hasn't yet appeared
in episodes but
apparently some 20 teens modern family
era westview sitcom that might include
one more creepy commercial so let us now
look back at all of these commercials to
decode their hidden meaning
to figure out what this sixth and final
one might be and before i begin thanks
to kiwiko for sponsoring today's video
more details about them later also i am
wearing our latest obsession shirt and
unusual couple which you can get to
support this channel at
newrockstarsmerch.com along with lots of
other great custom merch options
okay episode one promoted the toastmate
2000 from stark industries
the sound of iron man's repulsor warm up
can be heard on the plunger
[Music]
and then it beeps an ominous red light
seemingly forever
now we pointed out how this was a nod to
the stark bombshell that traumatized
wanda in pietro as children described in
age voltron we're 10 years old
having dinner the four of us and the
first shell hits two floors below it
makes a hole in the floor
but it doesn't go off on the side of the
shell
let's paint it one word it's dark by the
way the actor in these commercials is
ithmar enriquez an old buddy of mine
from la's improv community who did not
confirm much to me
except that the seemingly upside down
666 on the toaster was as expected since
editor hydra john's mom has this same
toaster
not a real easter egg did you see any of
this stuff while you were on set
that day did any of this stand out to
you i mean they saw a clock
episode 2 promoted the strucker watch
with the hydra logo named of course
after baron von strucker the hydra
scientist who experimented on wanda in
pietro in sokovia
episode 3 promoted hydra soak a bath
soap that many believe was a nod to the
hydra mind control soap that bill
coulson ranted about in the agency
shield framework simulated reality
episode that blue soap everyone uses
hydra loads it up with chemicals it
seeps into our bloodstream
and plants false memories into our
brains they want us to believe this is a
magical place
episode five promoted lagos paper towels
i know it's legos but the mcu for
whatever reason pronounces this nigerian
city as lagos i'm sorry take it up with
them
anyway it's a not to wanda's accidental
launch of crossbones suicide bombing
into a building filled with innocent
people another huge horrible casualty
that led to the sokovia accords and the
civil war conflict this commercial even
lasts a few seconds longer with some
extra drips
for when you make a mess you didn't mean
to
really underlining the red blood wanda
spill that still haunts her and then
episode 6 gave us
your magic yogurt which i believe
reflects wanda's confessed
loneliness and her paranoia over needing
magic to survive so that she won't turn
into a corpse like her loved ones
this magic is brought to her by a bro
toothy predator who says
there you go little dude and in the
scene right after this pietro says the
same thing
right on little dude chip off the old
maximum block you got super speed
clearly all of these things are
important to wanda's past but as fans
have started to look more into these
some interesting theories have begun to
gain steam
one theory suggests that the recurring
commercial man and commercial woman
are wanda and pietro's parents and as
stoked as i would be for ethmar to be an
adventure daddy
i don't think that's gonna be the case
now another theory is that each of these
commercials represent one of the six
infinity stones
this was posted recently on reddit but i
know some people were tweeting this at
me weeks before after episode 3 dropped
so forgive me i don't really know who
first started saying this but the idea
is that the stark toaster represents the
mind stone
i guess because the toaster kind of
looks like vision's robot face and that
blinking light
is the mind stone in his forehead struck
her watch for the time stone
hydra soak for the space stone because
it's a blue
cube like the tesseract logos paper
towels for the reality stone because
that red spilling liquid is kind of like
the ether
and now they're saying that yo magic
yogurt is like the soul stone
because i guess it's closer to that
leftover one than the power stone is
yeah don't get me wrong i love [ __ ] like
this but like many
infinity stone parallels observers have
derived from past mcu moments
there is a difference between
intentional easter eggs that the
creators of the stuff implied and
interpretive parallels
viewers infer both have artistic merit
and are worthy of discussion but only
the former can help us predict where
things are actually gonna go next and
looking at the actual thematic
intent of these commercials combined
with the remaining footage we have yet
to see in episode 789
we can make a pretty good estimation of
what these commercials will all
add up to and again thanks to kiwiko for
sponsoring this video so kiwiko
is defining the future of play by making
it engaging enriching and seriously fun
they create cool hands-on projects and
toys designed to expose kids to concepts
in steam
science technology engineering art and
math cubico is a great resource for
learning at home each monthly crate is
designed by experts tested by kids and
teaches a new theme through hands-on
learning and fun
cubico offers eight subscription lines
each catering to different age groups
and topics each box comes with all the
supplies needed for that month's project
so this month they sent me this
eureka crate and it lets you build your
own stereo headphones
i opened it up i found tools like this i
started working on it and thanks to a
little bit of help from off-screen
producer zack
just look at this finished project it's
so freaking cool and it's like awesome
that
this was made by new rockstar's hands
they include a booklet that has very
clear instructions and great tidbits
about the history of the speaker
technology
and some fun experiments that you can do
with your headphones get your heart out
dr
dre so kiwico believes that small
lessons today can mean big
world-changing ideas tomorrow and
sometimes when you're small it's easier
to think big
kimiko is teaching the skills of
innovation creativity and problem
solving today in the hopes that kids are
equipped to
better the world tomorrow it was really
fun for us to put these headphones
together and we're gonna think back on
the experience every time we pump some
cool jams so here's what you do just
check out kiwico.com
new rockstars for 50 off your first
month
of any crate click the link in the
description below okay the first five
commercials represent wanda's past
trauma the anti-stark rage she felt when
his artillery killed her parents
and froze her and her brother in fear
struck her making time for her as a
lab experiment hydra weaponizing her as
a mind controlling sorceress
her early forays as an avenger causing
the deaths of innocence and the conflict
that led to the team's dissolution
and following the death of vision
withering in isolation as a predator
offers her magic to survive magic that
if she doesn't tap into she fears that
she will die
there is a reason wanda is
subconsciously revisiting her past
trauma and it is because as this series
is based on house of m
and i believe heavily influenced by the
one other series about an omega level
marvel mutant legion
this series is all about wanda's mental
health
and going along with that theme and
since all of these commercials are
really
parodying the ways various progressing
decades of advertisers have targeted
women and moms do not be surprised if
this next commercial
in the modern family era is a
stereotypical pharmaceutical ad
medication for anxiety depression or
whatever hopefully undiagnosed condition
wanda has because no one wants to
accidentally mischaracterize any of
those very
real conditions everything we are seeing
could be wanda's
disastrously poor attempt to undergo
therapy
an introspective journey into her
subconscious
to work through this painful trauma with
reimagined
perfect sitcom lives that never ever
bring up the real history of her pain
when it does she just edits past it and
because wanda is a sorceress all of this
projects outward as a kind of hex
that traps all the nearby people inside
the spell and i still think she must
have been led into this by
a guide one with ulterior motives and
based on her weirdness last episode i'm
gonna guess it's agnes
aka the witch agatha harkness we're
actually gonna go into what we think
agatha's secret plan is on tomorrow's
episode of rogue theory be sure to check
it out
and you can continue this nerdy
conversation on new rockstar's official
discord server by becoming a patron at
patreon.com
new rockstars follow me at eavos follow
new rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for all of your wanda vision questions
thank you for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]